so this character you play
in christmas chronicles 2 is very kind
of like
dark and edgy and maybe not the typical
character you'd see in a family
christmas movie i'm curious
i'm curious how much of that kind of
energy came from you
personally how how much did you have a
hand in creating his look and his vibe
and stuff like that
yeah cause i i hate christmas
i'm joking that was you're about to log
out the zoom
yeah yeah you know this is not going to
be a fun unt um
no uh yeah i remember um
uh i was sitting down with the director
chris and all of them and they were like
hey we really want this character would
really love you to play him how do you
want him to
to lock him like i was like you guys
know how he looks
i'll just concentrate on like where you
want me to be as the character and where
you want
him to feel and when you watch when the
audience watches a film
how do they you want them to feel um
and they're like cool super great so i
had long hair the liver jacket the long
pants the big
boots um and i felt cool enough with the
the fingerless gloves
that was cool as well um so
yeah i was really kind of the small
touch as we were in costume and they're
like oh where do you want this i'm like
oh can i put that patch there
i can i put them there uh we're gonna
spray paint the stuff in the boots and
i'm like yeah go right ahead
um because i wanted him to look mean
like i didn't want him to look
like everyone sees the grinch and
everyone knows who the grinch is because
he's this green monster
like i want i want because he is a
redeeming arcana
i want him to really i want you to see
the change that he has
but still keep those characteristics
because he does like wearing the leather
jacket
he does like wearing the boots and even
though that looks not christmassy that's
who he is
but he's still you know he still evolves
in that
whilst keeping those similarities you
know what i mean so for me that was
important and that's why i wanted to
have a role in
making sure the character was
you know 100 percent i think you
achieved thumbs up and more uh
you talked about like just working on
where is he emotionally
in that moment were you thinking about
performing him
as an arc from beginning to end or was
it more scene to scene or what was it
like crafting this emotional journey for
him
yeah um so i work with this guy called
andrew mcelroy
um who's an acting coach um uh over in
vancouver
and british columbia where we shot um
and working with him i've worked i've
worked with him on deadpool and i've in
a few other films
and i love working with them because
it's almost like
when you do a film it's never like start
to finish
it's almost like the audience and the
camera is kind of you have this life
and then you're kind of slotted into a
place of that life but it
still continues it's never like start a
film
in the film so it was never like the art
kind of went up and down it was almost
like the camera is watching it
move straight you know what i do does
that make sense i sound like a
welcome to my genius interview um
that is how we're building it by the way
yeah um
for me i wanted it to i wanted you to
see him
like evolve into into like finding the
love and finding the warmth that he
wants because
in this film that's what belle's nickel
wants he just wants love but
he's kind of oversighted with greed and
and anger and kind of that so
yeah yeah what was it like seeing the
cgi elf version of that character
voicing voicing that version of that
character i was like
i look like a gremlin um so
watching me i had the long hair and
still the little little jacket on
um because the elves are like on set
they're like like these giant kind of
cube things
um so i was like what the hell is that
that's just like a blue cylinder
i know that's you i'm like okay cool um
uh i was crazy seeing the elephant doing
the voice as well because i can't really
get my voice high
so i would say and then they would like
prop it up with a whole lot of audio
stuff
um and then you even have like the
elvish language that they had like you i
had to learn some of that
because obviously i'm a human but i was
you know like you know a bit of alf
human and
kind of mixing it all so it was super
cool super crazy though
awesome guys who um did the cgi in there
yeah what was the process like learning
elvish was there like
a language creator on set helping you
with that
uh yeah there was a language creator but
um the thing was cool as i said andrew
mcelroy who i work with
he actually worked on like the star trek
um like films and that
so he did like a lot of like kind of
because there's a whole lot of different
languages in there
but basically sometimes they would have
elvish like scripted right and then what
it would mean
and then sometimes like um chris on set
or something he'll be like
yo just say um
like he would just say something random
and he goes yeah that
yeah that sounds like that and then i
would just say that um
so like a lot of the elvish was either
made up or was prepared earlier
um but they did have like these two um
actors on set who could do like
really good alpha voices and they would
come on soon they'll be like hey they
would have read the alpha lines in there
um so all of that was super cool it's
interesting to hear that
uh chris columbus was so spontaneous
with elements of it
because it's so special effects driven
and i'm curious you've been in a couple
special effects heavy films what is that
process like as an actor is it
more difficult than something like a
hunt for the wilder people or what is it
like
yeah like hunt for the i think also has
a do a budget obviously you know having
the budget to do
these big films so for like hump for the
water people
there's a shot on it where you like 360
and it's almost like a time lapse
almost and you go around and you see
with that there was no cgi the only
thing that was cgi did was the dog
everything else was like three other
doubles and you were just like ducking
under the camera and like running around
so you could get the shot
and like there was a giant segment in
that film where it was snowing but they
couldn't
they couldn't afford to move somewhere
else so we just did it in the snow
but like this one um christmas
chronicles
working on them is crazy because you
have these dudes they come in with these
like silver balls
these big old balls of silver and these
little sheets and
it's i'm kind of crazy to think you look
at it and you look at it on c and you're
like
it's hard to like talk to a tennis ball
or like talk to like a dude in a blue
glove like a dude in a more suit
um and then you see it on screen and go
wow it's like that's really what it
looks like so
you kind of have to picture the end
product um
because i i'm talking to a puppet like
talking to like this 50 year old guy
like holding a puppet like this is weird
um and then you see it and it's crazy
yeah uh
you mentioned it a little bit ago
deadpool 2 uh
i just have a a simple question about
that what's ryan reynolds really like
awful yeah um he seems like a
like i actually never really talked to
him he kind of um he had like this
you know the shower curtains he doesn't
like people looking at him so he kind of
he would walk around
with like a shower curtain hat like a
red kind of curtain
yeah um so i don't i don't know really
what he's like no he was a he was a
he's great um he's a real family man um
uh i remember i think blake had i don't
know what number child you're on but
they
they they had she brought their babies
along and and mum got the whole damn and
ryan reynolds
really loved the mom and i remember i
was one of the
i was sitting on set and and ryan um his
mom would say and he really missed him
and he's like hey jules and i'm like
yeah yeah yeah right and he's like can i
call your mom
like because i call her mama and she's
like can i call her mama i'm like bro go
right ahead like if
like i know your mum's my hair like go
ahead and and he and he ended up calling
my mom and i was talking to a lot of
times
he's a really great dude yeah and that's
even same with kurt as well like
thinking about it now like
these such big heavy hitters in the game
like working with kurt and him working
at santa he's really passionate
he loves what he does he loves what he
does he loves
what he does yeah he loves what he does
on set in there and you can see that his
experience has paid off and it is and
he's so wise man
yeah that's those are great kind of
anchors to have on set with you
um is there anything you can tell us
that you're particularly excited about
uh godzilla versus kong a film you're
appearing in coming up
um yeah yeah that's coming up um
it's been a long run um but i'm excited
for it to come out
um it's been a while since we shot there
so it should look good i should look
different i can't wait to see it
who doesn't like to see um i don't know
like godzilla vs con it's kind of it's
kind of a
it's a crazy film to describe i don't
know how you describe like
these two like a giant lizard and then
like a giant monkey it's like
it's kind of crazy so i'm yeah i'm
excited for when that comes down and i
can't wait
for people to see it um yeah but
no that's gonna be fun i can't wait yeah
what about you said you look different
in it
what's what's different about it well i
think because um we like we shot like we
shot it quite a while ago and you know
because i gotcha um i'm uh his mom was
how he's a young growing boy
um so i had longer hair in there blah
blah blah i wore glasses in it as well
i don't that's not a spoiler and i had a
wallet chain
um and so yeah this would probably look
different so yeah
well we'll put a spoiler alert on that
you wear glasses in godzilla versus